i'm just hearing from a very high level
government source telling me that it's
done it's done he needed a final posh
push rather but it is
done come back to you just a second rory
your thoughts on that that well
it sounds like it's all over k if you're
hearing it from someone very senior in
the government that it's all over i
think that is very much what we were
expecting and what has been looking
inevitable over the past few hours if it
seemed yesterday that boris johnson
thought he could carry on and get new
people in his top team it's become
incredibly evident this morning with the
departures of more key cabinet ministers
other cabinet ministers making clear
that they won't desert their posts for
national security reasons but urging the
prime minister to go it is game over and
it sounds from what you're saying and
what we're hearing from others in
downing street as if
the prime minister is now preparing for
that and will be
preparing to go
in the coming hours
that what's that going to look like so
come out and tell us
once it is confirmed we have not had
official confirmation of that from
downing street it's just what we're
hearing but
if it happens it will involve i'm sure
as we have seen with previous prime
ministers the lectern coming out
and the prime minister addressing
everybody who's here there's a lot of
people here on the street as we saw with
david cameron of the morning after
referendum when he resigned remember he
did that little shoot hum that little
tune to himself and later said it was to
stop him becoming too emotional theresa
may resigned and we may well see boris
johnson resign in the coming hours my
understanding is that
the prime minister did not want to
sign any resignation letter
but he has been pushed and pushed and
pushed this morning by some of his most
senior colleagues and then just a few
moments ago we heard from the chancellor
we did we are now
we can now tell you that we expect sky
news expects boris johnson to resign
today to resign in the coming hours
final straws were the departure of his
very loyal northern ireland secretary
and then the chancellor who has been
imposed for 36 hours who we heard have
told the prime minister the game was up
yesterday afternoon
publicly saying the prime minister must
go the government has lost integrity